bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans ça vous regarde de quoi
parle-t-on ce soir eh bien d'abord
d'agriculture le salon ouvre ses portes
sur fond de malaise dans le monde paysan
le président emmanuel macron met la
pression sur la grande distribution pour
que la guerre des prix cesse enfin on y
reviendra on parlera aussi de
l'agriculture biologique mettons
vraiment les moyens pour aider les
exploitants à passer au bio et le label
le label garantit t'il vraiment une
meilleure alimentation agriculture et
environnement peuvent ils faire bon
ménage c'est notre grand débat ce soir
pour ou contre le 49-3 face à
l'enlisement du débat sur la réforme des
retraites le gouvernement n'exclut plus
de passer en force la majorité pourtant
une partie d'entre elles s'y oppose et
le fait savoir et les français alors
comprendre est il que le gouvernement
est bien décide d'adopter ce texte sans
vote à l'assemblée
c'est la question que nous poserons à
marc fesneau le ministre en charge des
relations avec le parlement et notre
grand témoin ce soir sans oublier bien
sûr notre bloc-notes on va refaire la
semaine politique avec tous nos
chroniqueurs comme tous les vendredis ce
sera dans la deuxième partie de cette
émission je vois là ça vous regarde vous
avez le programme c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir marc
fesneau bonsoir genre et merci d'être
notre grande et moins vous êtes ministre
en charge des relations avec le
parlement on a hâte évidemment de vous
entendre sur les retraites et ce recours
aux 49 3 qui semble devenu inéluctable
au vu de l'enlisement des débats vous
nous direz si vous comptez oui ou non
recourir à cette arme à haut risque
avant les municipales mais vous êtes
aussi un élu du loir-et-cher région
agricole s'il en est et ça tombe bien
parce qu'on va parler agriculteurs et
notamment du bio ce soir avec vous
richard ramos bonsoir bonsoir député
modem du loiret karine jacquemart
bienvenue à vous vous êtes la directrice
générale de l'oms gfu droite france et
jacques fring merci d'être là vous êtes
maraîcher bio en seine et marne
convertis au bio depuis 40 ans pas de
bêtises vous cultiver fruits légumes et
céréales dans une ferme de taille
moyenne et vous êtes le vice-président
du groupe
le groupement d'agriculture du
d'agriculteurs biologiques d'île de
france je vous donne la parole dans un
instant merci à tous les quatre de
participer à cette émission mais d'abord
emmanuel macron qui durcit le ton qu
durci le ton vis-à-vis de la grande
distribution c'est dans le billet de
stéphane blakowski si j'ai bien compris
tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bonsoir
stéphane installez-vous alors si j'ai
bien compris ce soir rien ne va plus
entre le président et les agriculteurs
et l'église tributes ruedi durci le ton
de moi si j'ai bien compris rey le
président a carrément décidé à tendre le
bras des grandes enseignes de la
distribution pour les forcer à payer les
produits agricoles à un prix juste donc
vous avez que le président est adepte de
cette méthode qu'on appelle name and
shame qui consiste donc à désigner
nommément une grande marque quand elle a
un mauvais comportement pour que bas et
avec la pression d'opinions publiques
on change son comportement dans une
petite variante ce matin il n'a pas
montré les mauvais élèves du doigt il a
affiné cité des bons élèves
donc dans son interview disait ben bravo
lidl qui signent des contrats des
agriculteurs qui pomme comme ça peuvent
voir un peu plus sur le long terme leur
leur leur compte
et puis il a dit l'un d'eux qu'ils
n'étaient pas bien et cela attention sur
la dernière trace qui m'intéresse ce ne
sont pas des tendres cela moi non plus
le défilé cela tombe bien il dit même
alors évidemment on a l'impression
qu'ils s'apprêtent à livrer le prétend
une rude bataille contre la grande
distribution
ah oui je me sauve que là bas la
bataille a fallu commencer pas
aujourd'hui c'est une bataille qui a
commencé bad bad et qui est arrivé au
pouvoir en fait en demi en octobre 2010
est donc six mois après son élection une
priorité pour le président macron c'est
de faire une loi sur l'alimentation et
l'agriculture
donc on est à rungis il fait un grand
discours et une promesse aux
agriculteurs il n'est plus possible
aujourd'hui qu'en france un tiers des
agriculteurs gagnent moins de 350 euros
par an et je leur dis très clairement
nous devons permettre aux agriculteurs
de ne plus dépendre des aides et pour
cela nous assurer qu'ils soient
rémunérés ou juste prix de leur travail
ça c'est pour les mots qu'en est il des
actes qu est ce qui a changé dans les
faits ça n'a pas tardé efficacité en
tout cas dans le temps puisque le mois
suivant dès novembre ont signé une
charte de bonne conduite pour les
grandes enseignes et alors stéphane
travert qui était à l'époque le milieu
de l'agriculture dit que c'est un accord
historique puisque toutes les grandes
enseignes sont d'accord pour arrêter
cette guerre des prix là qui avait la
tête sous l'eau des agriculteurs on va
enfin les payer donc à un prix juste
et alors cette charte alors laden quoi
bien cette charte avaient tout prévu y
avait juste un petit défaut peut-être
c'est qu'elle n'était pas contraignante
ah bah mince alors parce que forcément
dès le mois de janvier à 2018 je passais
vous souvenez ça avait marqué les
esprits
les promos reprennent de plus belle ces
intermarché qui fait mouche
70% sur le nutella donc on comprend que
voilà malgré tout quand on voit ces
images la source de la guerre des prix
c'est quand même le consommateur
inquirer fait qui réclame des baisses de
prix sauf que en octobre 2018 une loi a
été votée la fameuse loi sur les états
généraux de l'alimentation pour défendre
le revenu des agriculteurs alors
normalement quand une loi est votée et
bien les hypermarchés sont obligés de la
respecter oui moi aussi je croyait
jusqu'alors je donne des mêmes
convaincus et a connu un cas qui est
semble démentir c'est le cas des deux
magasins leclerc c'est eux dont parlait
le président tout à l'heure en disant ce
qu'ils vont en belgique pour échapper à
la loi oui en 2016 leclerc à la haye
s'est associé avec deux allemands et a
déplacé sa rentrée de l'aja en belgique
pour échapper la loi française dès 2017
bercy repère la manoeuvre ils font une
note en disant est ce que c'est bien
normal on met la pression sur le clair
on se dit qu'on va finir par lui tordre
le bras pas du tout ce qui vient que
donc en juillet 2019 donc c'est bien
l'été dernier la secrétaire d'état à
l'économie libre ça suffit et elle
demande au tribunal de commerce de
coller une amende de plus de 100
millions d'euros au groupe leclerc en
écoute si cette amende est indolore
alors il ne se passe rien
c'est pour ça que dans cette situation
qui est emblématique de pratiques
illégales
nous avons fait le choix de prendre une
amende maximale c'est-à-dire trois fois
les montants que leclerc à récupérer sur
le dos de groupe sans contrepartie de
façon à ce que ja on arrête de ne plus
respecter de ne pas respecter la loi on
imagine qu'avec une aussi grosse amende
ça y est michel edouard leclerc est
rentré dans le rang à moi aussi
on va de surprise en surprise dans ce
dossier c'est incroyable vraiment en
fait je me disais si leclerc est menacée
il va céder le pot du tout ça
n'impressionne pas plus que ça il me dit
en gros à vous voulez m'emmener tribunal
de commerce mais moi j'irai la cour de
justice européenne puis rovira qui a
raison quant à savoir si le gouvernement
est content ou pas content je vous crois
qu'on peut dire que il s'en fout alors
dites moi vous vous rendez compte que on
nous reproche de choses on ne reproche
de vendre moins cher et on nous reproche
d'avoir une coopérative d'achat avec des
allemands et à bruxelles à bruxelles
et c'est nul et moi à mon âge avec 40
ans de pratique dans la distribution
toutes ces politiques là je les envoie
bas
les envoie balader et le président avec
c'est ça est-ce qu'il enverrait balader
le président est-ce que c'était un défi
je veux pas rajouter de l'huile sur le
feu moi je les ai un peu pris comme ça
appuie toi tu as le président avait
l'air de relever le défi à bon le quart
n'est pas un tendre
et bien moi non plus on va voir ce qu'on
va voir bah oui on va voir ce qu'on va
voir qui est le plus fort des deux
présidences que c'est le président de la
république ou est ce que c'est le
président du plus grand groupe
d'hypermarchés en france on attend la
fin
marc fesneau on a l'impression que dans
ce dossier vous n'arrivez pas à vous
faire obéir de quel côté est
véritablement le rapport de force on
peut douter qu'ils soient du côté de la
vérité c'est que depuis soixante ans 70
ans que la grande distribution c'est
vous avez dit c'est un combat depuis
2010 est au fond c'est un combat
quasiment depuis 40 ans qui a été le
combat d'ailleurs de l'extension des
mètres carrés
d'abord qui n'est pas un combat
complètement terminés ou en gros le
modèle français qui s'est construit
depuis 50 ans c'est un modèle qui est
très basé sur la très grande
distribution plus un mouvement qui n'a
pas été interrompue qui le monde hyper
concentration à la fois des hypermarchés
mais aussi des centrales de centrales de
d'achat et qui font peser sur les
producteurs une charge très lourde
la chose alors je suis passé c'est une
question de rapport de forces au bras de
fer mais la question ce n'est pas
monsieur leclerc et pour les autres
céderait simplement de respecter la loi
et quand on est mise des relations avec
le parlement je parle sous des feuilles
sous l'oeil de richard ramos qui est
député on fait respecter la loi donc
monsieur leclerc peut toujours dire ce
qu'il veut sur les antennes ou les
plateaux un moment faut faire respecter
la loi
reconnaissons que souvent c'est pas tant
le respect la loi que le détournement et
toutes les procédures qui sont faites
pour essayer d'échapper à la loi telle
qu'elle est rédigée parce qu' un certain
nombre gouvernement je pense pas
d'ailleurs vous passez par et nous seuls
de la volonté de le faire d'autres ont
essayé de le faire et à chaque fois on
s'est retrouvé avec des enseignes et des
dirigeants dans celles qui ont trouvé
des voies et moyens pour détourner la
loi et donc notre responsabilité c'est
de faire en sorte qu'on cesse ça avec je
crois la volonté aussi des consommateurs
rhissa ramos est ce que l'erreur c'était
pas de faire confiance à la grande
distribution pour se mettre d'accord par
filières professionnelles avec les
agriculteurs avec les intermédiaires
est-ce qu'il faut pas contraindre est ce
que cette fois avait pas trop gentille
mais moi je suis très à l'aise puisque
dans l'hémicycle c'était dans la loi et
galim j'ai dit en citant monsieur michel
edouard leclerc vous êtes un voyou ou à
titre personnel puisque voulait faire
votre enseigne à titre personnel
l'incarner j
dans l'hémicycle que c'était un voyou
parce qu'il avait fabriqué trois
générations de français auxquels on leur
a fait croire que bien manger c'est
acheter pas cher mais acheter pas cher
dans un saucisson chez michel edouard
leclerc
ses maîtres du sud dans un saucisson
pour sa retiennent de la flotte et
vendent aux pauvres de l'eau au prix de
la viande et j'ai dit aussi que les
caméras c'est dans les boxes de
négociation qu'il faut les mettre
parce que michel edouard leclerc parce
qu'il est sympa comme ça et on le croit
parce qu'il dit regardez comment
j'achète pas cher mais on n'achète pas
cherché michel edouard leclerc parce
qu'il a avant étranglé nos paysans alors
ça c'est pour le coup de gueule de
richard a aussi commandé mais que si
vous avez raison de le pousser parce que
je les y revient et on vous connaît pour
sa simplement vous est aussi député
pourquoi ya pas être plus de contraintes
sur ce tacle sur des grands 10e ya eu
des contraintes comme jamais il ya eu
c'est à dire quand on a été le chercher
et que bercy a été le chercher pour lui
faire payer des amendes
on n'avait jamais vu ça et aujourd'hui
on est en train de regarder pourquoi
michel edouard leclerc qui fait 100 %
quasiment de son chiffre d'affaires en
france il a besoin de monter des des
structures à l'étranger c'est moi quand
je monte des structures à l'étranger
normalement c'est quand les chefs
d'entreprises français font du business
à l'étranger eh bien on a tous compris
que c'est pour défiscaliser c'est pour
cacher le pognon c'est simple c'est beau
c'est pour que derrière ils payent pas
l'impôt qu'ils devraient payer et donc
je dis aujourd'hui que michel edouard
leclerc
quand il dit aux consommateurs je suis
le défenseur finalement mieux que les
politiques de la consommation mais c'est
parce qu'il est temps que notre pays
c'est parce qu'il est 30 les petits
paysans qui font des produits et donc
derrière il faut le combattre et il faut
que le politique soit plus fort
ce sont des amendes même si elles sont
restées en justice c est là qu à les
taper
il faut aller le taper et surtout il
faut aller dire au consommateur
quand vous avez une carte bleue votre
carte bleue elle est plus fort que le
bulletin de vote c'est dire que quand
vous achetez
si vous considérez que michel edouard
leclerc tu la paysannerie et bien
j'achète pas des produits à marque rock
fait de la politique avec votre carte
vous faites des choix politiques à
rennes jacques mercanton quand on milite
pour une meilleure alimentation
il faut que les agriculteurs et puissent
vivre de leur métier c'est tout est lié
mais bien sûr c'est le bilan de cette
cette loi alimentation attendre un peu
mais vous le dirai comment vous il est
très mitigé donc effectivement il ya
plusieurs problèmes il faut il faut les
prendre dans leur ensemble les traiter
chacun il est évident qu'il faut que les
agriculteurs puissent vie
de leur travail de même que il faut les
amener vers une agriculture plus
respectueuse de l'environnement et de la
santé élise et les y accompagner il est
hors de question que ça continue à être
les victimes
ensuite il ya la question du poids de la
grande distribution nous on le dit très
souvent dans la réglementation
européenne sur l'alimentation
dans le cas de lactalis par exemple la
grande distribution de façon générale a
aussi beaucoup trop d'impunité
quand est-ce que c'est la dernière fois
que la grande distribution a eu des
sanctions dissuasives lors d'un scandale
alimentaire y en a pas et foodwatch
avait avait porté plainte suite à la
sphère lactalis donc des les contaminer
parce qu'on se rappelle que plusieurs
distributeurs pas un seul avait manqué
alors restons donc un prix aussi de
répression et bien sûr à ce qu'enfin
niveau au niveau du caniveau de la loi
ils ont ils ont ils ont un énorme poids
économique sur les agriculteurs mais
aussi de façon générale et il faut qu'il
soit beaucoup plus responsables de leurs
actes maintenant sur l'alimentation en
général
le compte n'y est pas du tout après des
mois d'états généraux de l'alimentation
et de débats sur la loi alimentation
agriculture
on a obtenu très peu de choses pour une
alimentation plus saine on a obtenu la
suspension de l'additif dioxyde de
titane très bien et quelques éléments
sur les cantines collectives
mais la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
a encore beaucoup trop de substances
potentiellement dangereuses dans
l'alimentation
c'est pour ça que on se bat par exemple
pour supprimer des additifs controversé
pour la santé comme les additifs à base
de nitrites et de nitrates et que cette
pétition à c'est un combat dressa ramos
a là pour le coup c'est un objectif
commun de ce2 d'intérêt général a gagné
mais pas réellement salma et la pétition
qu'on a lancé avec yucca et la ligue
contre le cancer a déjà été signée par
presque 200 mille personnes parce que
c'est un vrai sujet de société les gens
veulent être protégés et manger sain
vous allez sur l'alimentation va parler
du bio dans un instant je me tourne vers
l'agriculture biologique vous êtes déjà
sur la grande distribution
vous aussi vous avez maille à partir
parce que si j'ai bien compris la grande
distribution se marge et comment sur
l'agriculture biologique
second constat 10e marche il ya des
moments vers des marges sur des produits
qui au départ soit un petit peu plus
cher à l'achat et donc forcément ça
amplifie
largement les prix de vente aux
consommateurs voient quelques jeunes
vaches pour le consommateur à l'antenne
puisque 83% sur la pomme de terre 109%
sur la tomate 149% sur l'album
enfin cette énorme ces tunnels est
énorme que choisir est historiquement je
pense que les agriculteurs bio sont
développées sur des circuits courts des
consommateurs qui acceptait de les
accompagner de reconnaître la qualité
des produits qu'ils faisaient et il est
payé mes magasins spécialisés aussi
qu'ont certains ont bien joué le jeu de
partenariat du développement de la bio
est un peu moins la grande distribution
donc on a la grande distribution
aujourd'hui évidemment elle là une part
importante quand même de la
commercialisation des millions c'est
donc du canton et maraîchers ont négocié
comment on s'imagine via les
intermédiaires des coopératives
ouais mais il ya moins d'intermédiaires
un transformateur quand on aime on
revendique un autre modèle et on a
développé une petite coopérative
spécialisée qui qui est qui rassemble
tout un tas de tous les producteurs de
la région en différentes différentes
cultures
pas spécialisé au contraire les
généralistes et si nous permet d'aborder
un marché relativement peu la grande
distribution
mais du coup la restauration hip hop on
est vite on
et moi je revendique eux que le modèle
agricole aussi doit contribuer à pouvoir
résister à la grande distribution
on a dit avant aux agriculteurs
grossiste spécialisé vous on a dit aux
coopératives grossistes et grossistes et
pour pouvoir être suffisamment gros face
à la grande distribution s'est jamais
été le cas elles sont toujours toute
façon croquer aussi par la grande
distribution
donc moi je revendique un autre modèle
agricole
comment comme pour nos cultures elle
devait diversifier nos modes de
commercialisation devait diversifier et
dans ce cas là on peut ranger quelques
exemples de collecte qui savent dire non
à la grande distribution
et puis finalement l'année d'après
berggren
d'un mot là dessus puisque cela montre
un reportage et que même en grande
distribution les produits bio ayew plus
humble c'est à dire que pour faire
simple quand j'achète un produit
traditionnel à 1 euro la grande
distribution
si elle fait une marge de 2,2 elle va le
vendre 2 quant à la chair du bio hm2f
est toujours une marge de 2 donc elle
vend 4 alors qu'au milieu la caissière
qu'à passer un produit beaucoup plus
importante dans le bios la caissière
capas effet la nuit leur le linéaire
mlle linéaire elle-même et de hockey
c'est là où on disait tout à l'heure ils
se goinfrent et donc toute la difficulté
du bio c'est d'aujourd'hui les gens
quand il achète du bio
ils veulent bien payer la valeur
intrinsèque supérieure et il faut pas
que la grande distribution viennent
casser ça pour que le bio viennent d'eux
finalement le traditionnel de demain
dire qu'au début on va attirer les
paysans en leur disant venez au
supermarché et après on va casser les
prix et donc quand on achète un produit
agricole
quand on achète un produit alimentaire
qui est sain et bien et le bio c'est le
cas pour l'instant
c'est ça qu'il faut défendre on est
capable un segment de vouloir mettre le
prix parce que on en accepte la valeur
de prix il faut pas laisser la grande
distribution mettre la main là dessus
parce que sinon ils abaissent rond comme
ils l'ont fait dans la dentelle dans les
cultures traditionnelles les prix vers
le bas et richard ramos pour défendre
des agriculteurs et notamment ceux qui
font du bio on comprend que cette
majorité elle promeut le bio avec toute
une série dead 50% produits bio dans les
cantines scolaires au plus tard le 1er
janvier 2022 c'est l'objectif de la loi
et galim on va en parler dans un instant
que l'on a voulu se poser cette question
au fond le bio il devrait partout dans
les étals du salon de l'agriculture
est ce que c'est le cas ahmed tazir a
mené l enquête porte de versailles
regarder
nous sommes à la veille de l'ouverture
du salon de l'agriculture les
préparatifs s'accélèrent 4000 animaux à
près de 1000 exposants six cent mille
visiteurs attendus
une édition particulièrement tournée
vers l'innovation et ses défis à le
renouvellement des générations
d'agriculteurs et maintien d'un revenu
décent pour les agriculteurs alors qu'on
leur demande aux agriculteurs de prendre
un virage écologique mais il est où le
bio il est ou au salon
allez venez avec moi on va aller fouiner
un petit peu je voulais vous demander
est ce que vous êtes bio est ce que vous
êtes passés au bio
pas du tout pourquoi pourquoi c'est la
plus grande film historique du monde où
c'est pas gagné chalet on tente encore
ils encouragent au bio arrive qu'ils
aient plus de de virage écologique et
tout ça qu'est ce que vous en dites vous
êtes sur le terrain
aujourd'hui c'est déjà une agriculture
raisonnée donc à mon avis ya plein de
gens d'être bio pour bien travailler
et oui aujourd'hui le bio nous nourrira
pas la planète donc il n'y aura pas de
la place pour tout le monde en bio mais
ils sont où les agriculteurs bio on va
tenter avec le groupe de jeunes là je
voulais savoir si vous étiez passé au
bio
pas encore après s'il ya quand même une
majorité qui pense qu'ils réfléchissent
me voit près démarche selon mon ça se
fait ainsi son ex pete tong pas quoi
les enveloppes pour le bio des régions à
son très vite très vite à sec
et puis la technicité après sa demande
du matériel qui coûte très cher matériel
de précision avec gps et touffah il ya
plein de choses qui rentrent en compte
bon c'est pas encore ça décidément je
vais pas le trouver mon agriculteurs
madame on voulait savoir si vous étiez
passé au bio
les vosges n elles sont élevés l'hiver
avec du fourrage naturel c'est à dire
que en faut des pâturages et là l'hiver
elles sont au fond un naturel pas dans
sillage etc
et l'été ont fait la transhumance au
mois d'avril
il monte dans les hauts pâturages et
redescendre en septembre pour pour
bénéficier nouveau pour l'hiver et
d'être au chaud du boulot sans le label
quoi bon on a pas besoin
regardez comme elles sont belles j'y
suis ouais je suis un éleveur bio
eureka il est là l'agriculteur bio
existent
vous répondez à ceux qui disent que le
bio c'est pour les riches alors ça pour
moi c'est d'abord c'est une bêtise parce
que là en fait effectivement produire
bio ça coûte un peu plus cher donc
forcément c'est normal que le produit
soit un petit un peu un peu plus cher je
dis bien un peu le terme peut être
important donc si votre priorité c'est
bien manger mais ça vous coûtera moins
bien moins cher de manger bio que tu
m'aimes paquet de clopes par jour ça
c'est sûr et puis aux portes samedi
c'est sûr c'est mieux mais l'ont pas
facile de trouver un agriculteur bio
c'est un peu à l'image du pays
emmanuel macron s'était engagé à ce que
15 % des surfaces agricoles soit cultivé
avec les critères de l'agriculture
biologique en 2022
aujourd'hui on en est à 7,5 pour cent
seulement on en est loin du compte
n'êtes vous pas foulé moutons bio quand
jack ma ça vous sur conques au salon ce
soit si compliqué de trouver des
agriculteurs bio on est loin du compte
semble-t-il
bon je sais pas quel pourcentage en est
exactement mais bien sûr on est on est
loin du compte
on est loin du compte parce qu'il faut
que ces pratiques s'étendent mais on est
aussi loin du compte parce que le bio
c'est formidable pour ce que c'est mais
ça ne répond pas à tous les problèmes
non plus juste avant d'y venir vous
allez nous donner les labels c'est ce
qu'il est ce qu'il est garanti ou non
mais quand un agriculteur dit nous on
fait de l'agriculture raisonnée
et que c'est au fond presque pareil
voire pareil la raison pas oui ces
débats on l'est on l'est on les connaît
et c'est mieux de faire de l'agriculture
raisonnée que pas raisonner mais quand
on n'atteint pas les indicateurs les
critères qui sont dans le cahier des
charges du bio c'est quand même quand on
fait quelque chose de différent et que
ces indicateurs dans le cahier des
charges du bio sont pas arrivés par
hasard
voilà maintenant je le répète bien sûr
qu'il faut aller vers du changement bien
sûr qu'il faut changer les pratiques
bien sûr que tous ces pesticides
il va falloir finir par réussir à les
réduire et l'équité surtout qu'on les
retrouve dans notre assiette et que les
agriculteurs sont les premières victimes
mais il faut accompagner les
agriculteurs ça ne doit pas être fait
contre eux ça doit être fait avec eux
mais ça doit être fait on les a forcées
depuis les années 60 tous ces
agriculteurs à utiliser ce modèle
intensif accompagnons les pour en sortir
et pas à la hauteur des semences ce plan
de soutien mais décidons d'en sortir par
exemple l'union européenne qu'à
prolonger le glyphosate pour cinq ans
elle n'a pas décidé d'en sortir dans
cinq ans elle a fait la politique de
l'autruche en disant on reporte la
décision à dans cinq ans donc au moins
acton qu'on veut sortir de ce modèle là
de ces produits qui sont nocifs et
encore une fois à commencer par les
agriculteurs
pourquoi c'est si non c'est ce que vous
venez dire très justement je pense que
ce qui est devant nous et la question de
la transition
je partage vraiment ce que vous avez dit
sur le fait que l'on fait pas les
transitions contre les gens ou en
opposant les ans les gens les uns aux
autres je pense que il ya plusieurs
étapes me semble-t-il vous l'avez un
petit monsieur sur sur la transition je
pense que l'intérêt des circuits courts
l'intérêt de la proximité de
l'agriculteur ou de celui qui fait de
l'alimentation si je peux dire avec les
hits et citoyen c'est que petit à petit
se crée un lien qui amène au final vers
le bio et que donc c'est le chemin qu'on
a à faire avec un certain nombre des
cultures la deuxième chose que je
voulais dire est ce que vous avez dit au
fond tout à l'heure c'est que le bios ça
doit être aussi un changement de modèle
y compris dans la grande distribution
parce que si c'est le même modèle qui
s'applique
ce qu'a dit richard ramos d'une certaine
façon le modèle va faire que seuls ceux
qui auront le plus de moyens pourront
accéder au bio or le changement de
pratiques agricoles doit s'accompagner
d'un changement de mode de consommation
et donc y compris de mode de
distribution parce que si on ne change
pas vous l'avez d'ailleurs dit au début
je crois de notre conversation
si vous changez pas l'ensemble du modèle
en fait il y aura toujours quelque chose
qui empêchera qu'on accède un certain
nombre d'éléments alors il ya des
éléments qui ont été faits dans le cadre
des états généraux de l'alimentation
dans le texte rien n'est jamais parfait
vous m'entendrez jamais parce que je
pense que
l'acte politique fait qu'il faut aussi
savoir évaluer on verra dans quelques
mois
il ya des négociations de ce deuxième
partie là qui ont lieu jusqu'à la fin du
mois de février début mars
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
participent à roncq
le modèle qui s'est construit depuis 60
ans et après tout c'est le modèle qui
avait été demandé c'est la séparation
des activités de conseiller de vente
pour essayer de faire en sorte que ceux
qui vendaient les produits ne sont pas
ceux qui conseillent en même temps les
agriculteurs dans leur orientation vie
on va voir comment tout ça se met en
route mais reconnaissons que c'est un
chemin long et qu'il faudra faire avec
les agriculteurs
ce qu'il faut c'est leur donner le cap
et leur dire que personne ne dérivera du
cap même si les transitions sont un peu
longs que personne ne pense qu'on va
mollir comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
sur la grande distri attendait la
volonté politique oui oui je pense
qu'elle voit là on entend voir deux sons
de cloche différents le terrain c'est
quoi parce qu'on vient d'entendre
certains agriculteurs dire c'est bien
gentil mais ça coûte beaucoup plus cher
une fois qu'on y est on gagne sa vie
mais encore faut-il pouvoir y passer
vous voulez les aides elle requérait
indiquent les aides comme dans mon cas
ça représente relativement peu à moins
de 5 % de mon chiffre d'affaires donc
c'est pas c'est pas énorme pour des uns
pour des agriculteurs est venu à qui
représente qui ont beaucoup plus d'être
que ça y compris nous selon ceux qui qui
traite beaucoup
voilà donc ce que je sais moi je voulais
j'ai perdu vous avez l'impression d'être
suffisamment accompagné puisque vous
vous projetez aussi des régions
certaines régions soutiennent lecture
via le développement la culture
biologique et mais on a quand même
l'impression que au niveau de la pac
c'est pas encore ça
on fait un bruxelles richard ramos la
commission des finances du sénat accuse
d'état de communication trompeuse sur
les sur les aides au bio non mais il
faut faire attention aux aides sur le
bio faut pas qu'on reproduise les mêmes
schémas
aujourd'hui il faut que le consommateur
parce qu'il ya de la valeur dans le bio
soit aussi capable de vouloir le payer
au juste prix et donc plus que permettre
l'autonomie de nos paysans si on remet
nos paysans bio sous perfusion on casse
c'est un vrai danger
il ya quelques difficultés la très
concrète à régler notamment pour des
agriculteurs que monsieur c les marchés
publics hier qu'aujourd'hui quand ils
font des marchés publics dans le bio
notamment dans la restauration scolaire
en ile de france et ailleurs finalement
ça ne permet pas de temps en temps de ré
de de pouvoir gagner des marchés alors
que c'est des gens qui dès du produit
bio qui vient d'ailleurs et donc il va
falloir retravailler s'est ouverte et
moi compris et bien par exemple quand tu
es en ile de france
on va lancer un appel d'offres dans les
restaurations scolaires sur du bio et
bien parce qu'il ya des marchés de
concurrence eh bien il ya du bio qui va
pouvoir répondre moins cher mais qui
vient en dehors de france est donc
finalement nos agriculteurs bio en
proximité alors que le but c'était de
faire du local et du local bio ils vont
se retrouver en difficulté
il va vendre et donc sa section de
parler local dans les voiles à lâcher
plus vite et donc la difficulté c'est
que dans le dentelle qu'on a qu'on on a
construit les marchés locaux jusqu'à
présent on n'a pas la possibilité de
faire bénéficier le fait que ça soit
locale et ce dans la rue c'est interdit
c'est illégal et et nos paysans seraient
taper dessus il faudra qu'on regarde ça
mais surtout ce qu'il faut vraiment
faire c'est penser qu'aujourd'hui il
faut pas rêver re c'est comme on a fait
on était de la fourche à la fourchette
c'est à dire que qu'on produisait on
mettait de la subvention il y avait une
fourchette pour le manger
on est maintenant passé de la fourchette
à la fourche c'est à dire que le
consommateur va déterminer les
productions et c'est parce que le
consommateur se dit en accompagnant la
le les gens qui font du local les gens
qui font du bio on va en accepter le
prix est donc en acceptant le prix c'est
le consommateur qui est lié direct au
producteur
donc on n'aura pas la mainmise de ces
gros qui sont au milieu l'alimentation
chez les enfants journée qu'on en dise
un mot parce que le voilà le temps file
à l'essai fils karim jacquemart vous
avez un combat là dessus au sein de
foodwatch tout à fait parce que du coup
le bio c'est bien encore une fois pour
ce cahier des charges par exemple il ya
48 additifs autorisés dans le bio
338 en europe dans le reste de
l'alimentation donc il ya du mieux mais
semé mais ça ne répond pas à tous les
problèmes et pourriez que les normes bio
sont insuffisantes en france
oui bah alors elles ne répondent pas à
tous les problèmes mais on peut toujours
l'améliorer donc c'est mieux mais ça ne
couvre pas tous les problèmes et
notamment je profite parce qu'il ya une
réforme là un projet de loi qui va
passer à l'assemblée nationale qui va
commencer à être discuté en commission
la semaine prochaine après les retraites
sur l'audiovisuel d'accès et donc les
commissions concernées la commission des
affaires économiques mais aussi la
commission des affaires culturelles ont
commencé à en parler la semaine
prochaine
c'est un c'est un projet un objectif
recommandé par l'organisation mondiale
de la santé qu'on a déjà porté lors de
la loi alimentation agriculture mais qui
malheureusement avait été défendue par
certains députés mais pas adoptée il ya
un enfant sur six en france qui sait en
surpoids ou obèses un enfant sur six en
france en 2020
c'est aberrant c'est pas une fatalité
est ce qu'on sait c'est que une des
causes c'est parce qu'ils sont exposés
beaucoup trop à la publicité et au
marketing
y compris pour des produits trop gras
trop sucré trop salé
donc c'est très simple il faut
réglementer et là ça s'appelle et en
direct et la bourrine forme de lobbying
de noël j'ai vous avez toute la bien vos
droits et vos faire-part ans il y avait
je viens déjà m'en demande en fait on
entend bien dépasser leurs problèmes
c'est celle à venir de la santé mais au
fond quoi alors vous prenez vous prenez
bien maintenant je vais rédiger le coup
tellement de composants modem qui est
très attaché à sa reprendra l'idée qui
est défendu par food watch je veux dire
c'est évident l'organisation mondiale de
la santé et par le ms évidemment même
peur et donc dialoguer avec des gens les
uns et les autres c'est ça et je peux
vous le dire le groupe modem je serai je
serai avec eux nous nous allons
reprendre cette idée là parce que à la
fois il faudra avoir raison économique
d'ailleurs comment on déstabilise pas un
marché économique commun dans dans
l'audiovisuel public il faut pas faire
en sorte que ça déstabilise le marché la
publicité et de et donc les programmes
mais il faudra aussi qu'on réponde à des
problèmes de santé publique est là avec
un vin un gamin sur six en france qu'est
tank est en surpoids
il faut faire quelque chose dont on est
derrière ça il faut dans les lycées
aignan et il faut que ce soit
contraignant les avions ne pas
reproduire la même erreur du début de la
discussion parce que le problème c'est
que le projet de loi prévoit des
engagements volontaires des entreprises
non il faut que les législateurs protège
les vous avez raison sinon si on fait
confiance aux industriels pour faire ça
on n'y arrivera pas c'est comme si on
demandait à une dinde de voter pour les
fêtes de noël et quelque chose me dit
que vous aurez des
vous dire en dehors de ce studio merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce débat
marc raynaud vous restez avec nous on va
évidemment parler maintenant de ce débat
ou de ce nom débat c'est au choix sur
les retraites ce sont trois chiffres
dont personne ou presque ne veut
entendre parler et pourtant elle a
semblé bien il est surtout le sont ces
chiffres sur toutes les lèvres c'est le
fameux article 49-3 de la constitution
synonyme de passage en force du
gouvernement et d'adoption sans vote à
l'assemblée le gouvernement ne l'exclus
plus je vous le disais qu'en pensent les
députés florilège de réactions regarde
et je le souhaite pas parce que à 49,3
ça veut dire une rupture brutale de
discussion alors que la discussion se
fait elle est longue
enfin on peut prendre deux mois je n'y
suis pas favorable parce que je pense
que nous devons le débat jusqu'au bout
aux françaises et aux français encore
faut-il qu'ils puissent avoir lieu pour
le moment nous débattons
de l'alinéa 2 après avoir débattu
pendant plusieurs jours de l'alinéa 1
il faut ramener de la sérénité il faut
tel au fond au fond des débats
mais pour cela ça suppose qu'on nous
dise pas à la fin de toute façon il y
aura une décision léonine celle de
couper court au débat
l'ultime passage en force effectivement
ce serait le 49 3 et on voit d'ailleurs
que depuis 24 heures et après seulement
trois quatre jours de débats alors qu'on
nous annonce trois semaines de débats
ils sont déjà en train de s'impatienter
de une et de deux de créer disons les
conditions ne travaille à créer les
conditions du caractère inéluctable du
49 3 en somme qu'ils envisagent de
passer en force ce qui n'était
évidemment pas acceptable
si vraiment il faut en arriver aux 49 3
nous soutiendrons si le gouvernement
prend cette décision
cette décision parce que y'a un moment
faut sortir et ceux qui courent qui
écriront sans doute au vous avez vu leur
ont bien cherché et en fait c'est
clairement ce qu'il cherche avec ce jeu
qui auxquels ils jouent qui est un jeu
dangereux
bonsoir stéphane et des pierres enfin
c'est vous qui suivez ce long débat
cette course de lenteur dans l'hémicycle
pour lcp et au quotidien j'en profite
pour saluer tous nos joyeux chroniqueurs
du vendredi camilli gones le code de
l'express bertrand dicale pour france
info qui va nous faire chanter
camille saféris vous allez voir marc
fesneau il va vous faire découvrir les
députés un peu autrement je suis sûr que
vous ne les avez jamais vu comme ça et
alex taylor
bienvenue à vous pour toute l'actualité
européenne revient en retraite avec vous
stéphanie alors menace de 43 49 3 plus
forte que jamais à ce stade du blocage
le gouvernement ne l'exclus plus et ça
non le gouvernement ne l'exclus plus ils
ne voient surtout pas d'autre solution
pour sortir de l'impasse surtout s'il
veut tenir son objectif faire adopter
définitivement cette réforme des
retraites avant l'été à l'assemblée
personne ne veut du 49-3 mais tout le
monde semble s'y résigner le premier ni
s'ils n'étaient pas favorables mais les
choses semblent là aussi bouger alors
son temps l'ombre du 49-3 planer une
dizaine de députés ont publié une
tribune pour s'y opposer alors c'est une
tribune signée par six parlementaires de
l'ailé gauche de la majorité et des
anciens marcheurs écouter à
bangai o qui est apparenté au groupe la
république en marché qui explique
pourquoi elle ne veut pas de feu 49,3 ça
une forme quelque peu d'autoritarisme
aussi c'est l'imposition l'imposition
d'un projet de loi sans débat sans aller
jusqu'au fond je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce
projet de loi beaucoup de français elle
attendait beaucoup de français ont élu
est aussi emmanuel macron sur le sujet
ça fait deux ans que des députés comme
moi nous travaillons sur le sujet avec
le gouvernement
et ça méritait effectivement un débat
sur le fond et on aurait pu enrichir
encore au delà ce texte initial alors au
delà de cette poignée de députés
d'autres élus de la majorité ce qui sont
parfaitement dans la ligne ne veulent
pas du 49 3 mais ils sont en train de
s'y préparer et dans tous les cas il n'y
a aucun doute la majorité se rangera
derrière la décision du gouvernement il
c'est l'opinion aussi j'imagine que le
gouvernement prépare aussi
alors ça veut dire quoi si c'est pas la
6e 49 3 va avoir lieu mais quand est ce
qu'on sait et bien il ne faut dégainer
ni trop tôt ni trop tard le gouvernement
le sait bien et ils cherchent le bon
moment et le bon moment pour l'exécutif
c'est quand l'opinion vous l'avez dit
sera prête
ou du moins quand il sera possible
d'expliquer qu'il ne s'agit pas de
censure et des débats mais de débloquer
une situation
il faut attendre que l'idée infuse dans
l'opinion explique un député est
d'ailleurs la majorité s'y emploient ça
fait trois jours qu'elle répète que s'il
n'y a pas de débat de fond c'est à cause
de nos positions inverses il y a ceux
qui veulent aller très vite là c'est
plus possible on ouvre une tribune
permanente à l'opposition il faut
tourner la page plaide un ténor de la
majorité
mieux vaut le faire maintenant qu'avant
que juste avant les municipales qui
auront lieu je vous le rappelle mi mars
alors est ce que ce sera la semaine
prochaine ce 49 3 ou la première semaine
de mars
le gouvernement est seul maître des
horloges en attendant les merveilles
moubarak fait nos envois demandé marc
fesneau
en attendant les débats continuent très
très doucement à l'assemblée et florian
bacheliers un des questeurs donc qui
tient les cordons de la bourse du palais
bonbons a sorti sa calculette sur
twitter il a fait savoir que chaque
journée deux séances coûtait 1 million
500 mille euros ce qui lui a valu de
très nombreuses critiques
si beaucoup stéphanie on va revenir sur
pas mal de sujets de votre papier mais
d'abord marc fesneau
le 49 3 était la seule issue possible
09/03 il existe dans la constitution
c'est pas une invention vous dites qu'il
ya trois chiffres 49 3 4 9 vous pourrez
aussi donné trois chiffres qui sont et
43 mille quarante deux mille amendements
déposés par un certain nombre de groupes
et majoritairement par le groupe de la
france insoumise et le groupe gdr
puisqu'ils collet y collectionne si je
peux dire les trois quarts avec audi
encore du nombre d'amendements
je vous donnais le deuxième chiffre
c'est que sur un certain nombre de
savants noirs depuis attendait depuis un
certain depuis le début quasiment du
débat à ces amendements s'ajoute un
certain nombre de sous-amendements alors
15 20 40 parfois sur le même amendement
dont vous faites les multiplications
voyez le le potentiel comment dirais-je
démultiplicateur sur chaque amendement
de la part des oppositions on est à cinq
cent mille 1 million au gré des choses
donc ça ses preuves
et puis le deuxième site puis troisième
suivre ces nous sommes le cinquième jour
du débat et nous en sommes encore sur le
deuxième alinéa de l'article 1
donc c'est pour la nourrice à refaire
handicapés rythme il faudrait 150 jours
ça fait cinq mois mais là le débat on
est même 450 je ne m'attendais à ce
rythme là on n'est même plus à 150 jours
c'est riesch a fait rentrer tout à fait
raison de rappeler ça c'était démarrage
de discussion avec quarante mille
amendements avec les sous-amendement
qu'on a on est plutôt à 300 jours 600
jours je veux dire vous repose ma
question alors attendez sur le 42e pour
faire remonter du gouvernement ce n'est
pas nous qui produisons on voit pas
inversé on va pas inverser la charge si
vous permettez la volonté du
gouvernement c'est d'aller au débat nous
avions prévu 15 jours de débats nous
avons prévu d'allonger à trois semaines
de débats ce n'est pas à nous qu'il faut
poser la question de savoir si le rythme
va s'accélérer et s'est accélérée à ce
rythme là ça peut pas faire de mal
on va dire les choses comme elles sont
et c'est pas violences faites aux
oppositions que de faire 2 nous on veut
aller on l'a dit depuis le début on veut
aller au fond du texte ce que cette
majorité ce gouvernement il pense que ce
texte pour ça un certain nombre
d'avancées pour le pays qui sont
nécessaires et qui sont justes et donc
nous ne lâcherons pas on est au
cinquième vous n'êtes pas responsable
invisible
telle était gay vous dis aussi que la
volonté dans ces gars là on fait quoi la
volonté sable mais attendez on ou
cinquième jour du débat on est vendredi
nous avons fait le choix d'ouvrir ce
week-end pour faire en sorte que les
débats puissent se prolonger
peut-être que de la part de l'opposition
en tout cas de cette opposition qui veut
faire de l'obstruction et qui la
revendique c'est pas la peine de se
cacher de 2 mondial de fierté de faire
l'obstruction pas leurs parlementaires
parce que après tout c'est un outil 1
ceci dit on n'est jamais rentré marisa
rené guénon mais exige je connais le nom
mais je dis je ne vais pas regarder
autour de vous montrer des archives en
2010 la réforme des retraites à l'époque
c'était l'opposition socialiste elle a
usé mais c'est tous ces moyens de
procédure c'est tout à fait jusqu'au
bout dit mais moi je ne désespère pas et
y compris d'ailleurs dans les rangs de
l'opposition et un certain nombre
demande de l'opposition chez les lrg un
certain nombre de socialistes chez eux
la volonté de débattre au fond et quand
vous les croisez dans les couloirs ici
il regrette aussi de ne pas pouvoir
aller au fond du dossier donc moi je ne
désespère pas au cinquième jour que
l'esprit de raison revienne et que au
fond ce qui est l'esprit et la lettre la
lettre et l'esprit du débat démocratique
qu'on revienne et qu'on puisse aller au
fond des débats sur un certain nombre de
challenges justement une petite partie
de la gauche dans votre camp et là je
parle des marcheurs qui vous réclame
plus de temps et c'est une manière de
vous dire ce calendrier contraint c'est
un peu un piège dans lequel il est en
train de tomber ils vous demandent du
temps et pourquoi donc ne pas siéger
pendant la trêve électorale c'est à dire
au delà des fameuses trois semaines dont
vous parliez je prends mon temps parce
que c'est compliqué technique des votes
normalement le texte doit être terminée
le 6 mars l'idée ce serait d'aller au
delà c'est la mère des batailles c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est le gouvernement
prenez votre taux très bien et quand on
a devant nous 150 jours ou six jours de
débat on arrête quand mais je parle de
cas des normes et même si je la vois mon
nom mais la traîne comme il ya ce qu'on
dit et la réalité des choses
nous sommes ce soir au deuxième alinéa
de l'article 1 et nous avons cinq jours
de débats il ya soixante cinq articles
je suis pas très fort en maths mais
enfin il suffit de faire des
multiplications pour dire que la
question n'est pas de savoir si on finit
le 3 mars le 6 mars au 25 mars
la question c'est quelle année au film à
quel moment on se dit qu'on y avait
rappelé
si morgan va regarder comment se
déroulent les débats moi je suis par
nature pas désespérer de la volonté qui
peut s'exprimer collectivement d'essayer
de débattre y compris dans la
controverse à un cherche pas on cherche
pas consensus
manifestement n'y en a pas mais tant
mieux mais au moins qu'on puisse
débattre et donc je ne désespère pas à
cette date à date
au cinquième jour de ce débat qu'on
puisse est drôle parce que vous le
saviez mieux que moi emmanuel macron a
subi le 49-3 d'une certaine façon sur
son texte lorsqu'il était ministre de
l'économie
c'était la loi macron avec notamment la
question du travail le dimanche et l'a
très mal vécu on connaît la suite de
l'histoire pour c'est que les français
seraient prêts à comprendre que vous
usiez de cette arme là dans un contexte
électoral
le français alors que l'infection au
président d'attenté les gens d'être
assez à l'écouté invite les français à
regarder qui fait preuve d'autoritarisme
dans le débat c'est pas nous n'avons
très peu de temps de parole et le
gouvernement et la majorité et même une
partie des oppositions qui s'en plaint
dans l'hémicycle 80% du temps de débat
est réservé à 33 voire cinquante
parlementaires c'est très bien les
droits de l'opposition sont très bien
respectée dans cet exercice là donc on
va pas inverser les choses non plus de
ce point de vue là faut pas exagérer le
j'entendais tout à l'heure une
parlementaire apparenté à la république
en marche d'hier c'est une preuve
d'autoritarisme l'autoritarisme n'est
pas chez nous nous nous voulons débattre
et comme nous sommes en évaluent le coût
de l'obstruction à un million cinq cent
mille euros par jeu
ce qu'il faut éviter de se rentrer dans
ce genre d'exercice parce que ça mais je
suis je sais pas d'où sort le gym agit
là aussi je suis pas très bon maintenant
c'est le budget attendait c'est le
budget j'imagine que c'est le budget
annuel ramenée au nombre de jours
c'est à rassembler c'est qu'est ce que
vous pensez d'arguments et ben je vous
joins de répondre je pense que c'est un
mauvais argument parce que la démocratie
si on accrédite la thèse que la
démocratie n'a pas un coup on va sur un
chemin qui est assez dangereux parce
qu'après je sais comment faire des
économies pour passer de 500 millions
deux cent cinquante vous réduisez par
deux le nombre de jours voyez ce que je
dis absolument si je suis heureux ce
rappel est dans votre majorité mais on
peut avoir des accords sans que ce soit
un drame apocalyptique assez sûre et
j'assume leed
et que la démocratie ou faut jamais se
laisser entraîner soi-même et jeu comme
je le dis aussi aux oppositions dans ce
qui ressemblerait à quelque chose d'une
facilité de langage et qui accréditerait
la thèse que la démocratie n'a pas de
coups parce que je sais comment ne pas
faire les faire des économies
démocratique vous supprimez les
parlements et vous installez des gens
qui porte des étoiles de généraux et
mais ce n'est pas ma conception de la
démocratie la démocratie c'est pas ça la
démocratie c'est des parlementaires
c'est des fonctionnaires c'est des gens
qui travaillent sur les textes et donc
de leurs collaborateurs et donc si c'est
ça qu'il faut préserver et donc nous
rentrons pas dans ce débat là il me
semble que ce n'est pas autant le débat
de l'obstruction est un vrai débat
autant de dévotion n'est pas un monde où
il ya la démocratie parlementaire que
vous vous défendez avec force on vous
entend il ya la démocratie sociale aussi
et cette conférence de financement en
cours on a l'impression qu'elle prend un
peu lola de deux syndicats menacent de
claquer la porte
ce qui s'est passé la semaine dernière
sur les sujets de pénibilité je me
semble qu'il ya d un certain nombre de
sujets qui avancent sur la transition
public privé il ya un certain nombre de
sujets qui avance sur les mécanismes qui
vont permettre de façon dont des lettres
j'étais confiant vous dit il en sort
rien mais je vous dis qu'il en sort des
choses n'est pas l'action de confiance
pas confiance je regarde la réalité des
choses et je vous dis simplement que la
démocratie sociale sur les quatre sujets
qui avaient été ouverts par le premier
ministre elle a avancé la semaine
dernière et donc on pourrait le traduire
dans le texte je vous réserve qu'on
puisse arriver un jour à l'article
concernerait mais ne me demandez pas
moins un argument également d'ailleurs
que les députés et pas seulement de
l'opposition quelques-uns dans la
majorité d un texte à trous ce n'est pas
une question aussi importante que le
financement ce n'est pas l'argent mais
attendez le financement alors devenions
deuxième partie à deuxième partie de la
démocratie sociale de question du
financement ne porte pas sur le système
cible universelle par répartition elle
porte sur la mise à l'équilibré du
système actuel c'est assez clair dans
courrier qui a été fait par le premier
ministre aux syndicats qui ont décidé de
s'engager les souffles laissons les
choses ferme les songes que les choses
se faire la cgt n'est pas envie de
s'engager dans ce sujet là au fond la
cgt et ce qui est une surprise
manifestement pas depuis le débat monte
à la fois contre la réforme et il pense
qu'il n'y a pas de sujet budgétaire on a
le droit d'être aussi d'accord avec
monsieur martinez ce n'est pas qu'un
accord est encore possible avec
viens de gêner rire cette conférence il
ya évidemment des positions
contradictoires juger c'est d'essayer de
faire converger un certain nombre de
positions bon merci beaucoup je suis
prêt à me détendre un peu on a compris
que 40 leur toit non mais on va passer à
des sujets plus légers l'heure en tout
cas ce qu'ont très bien que le 49-3 si
les dégainer ce ne sera pas votre faute
si vous vous dégainez ce n'est pas une
arme à feu n'a pas été créé par le
général de gaulle michel debré qui était
bon paf pas donc on déjà m 49 3 ces deux
constitutionnel ça a été au cul voilà
mais simplement on ne veut pas
l'utiliser je le répète mais allez poser
la question à ceux qui s'y opposent par
l'ass qui se compose pas l'obstruction
au débat parlementaire qui prennent leur
responsabilité est ce que c'est un peu
facile de venir faire porter ce sera la
faute des insomnies à vous en tant que
c'est pas là que c'est pas la faute
l'obstruction et vient d'où merci
beaucoup aller on se détend le bloc
notes c'est parti moi je sais pas avec
vous caby on va commencer à parler donc
dû des municipales les municipales côté
rassemblement national c'est la panique
c'est ça oui alors pour rappel si vous
voulez être candidat aux municipales il
vous reste plus que six jours il faut se
dépêcher la date limite c'est le 27
février pour déposer sa candidature et
surtout sa liste est effectivement du
côté du rassemblement national ça rame
dur j'ai contacté pas mal de tête de
lise pas mal de délégués départementaux
et il s'arrache tous les cheveux il faut
trouver des noms enfin il faut surtout
trouver des femmes pour avoir une
candidature mix parce que oui dans les
villes de plus de 1000 habitants pour
rappel il faut un homme une femme pour
présenter la lys la semaine dernière le
parti a envoyé un mail à tous son
fichier en leur demandant s'il vous
plaît rejoignez nous rejoignez les
listes pour nous aider concrètement 600
candidats ont été investi tête de liste
mais peut-être que seulement 500 listes
irons jusqu'au bout 450 419 plus
pessimistes à l'aller c'est peu et c'est
beaucoup moins certainement qu'en 2014
où le parti présente et 197 liste pour
marine le pen qui a fait de
l'implantation locale
sa priorité
marqueurs ça fait vraiment mauvais genre
si on passe la barre des 500 listes j'en
parlais avec un élu du parti hier qui me
confié en off si on est trop bas ça sera
impossible de cacher notre effondrement
c'est un symbole de la faiblesse du
parti à tous les niveaux alors ça donne
quoi si on regarde la carte la carte de
france
alors selon des comptes très précis qu'a
été fait par mes collègues de france
inter le rassemblement national sera
absent de 25 préfecture sur 100 un quart
des préfectures regarder cette carte
c'est toutes les zones en blanche sur la
france mont-de-marsan le plus en velay
colmar vezoult je ne vais pas vous faire
la liste de tous les endroits toutes les
villes où sera absent le rassemblement
de la corse
complètement absent non y sera encore
demain mais il n'y aura pas de liste
rassemblement national à orléans par
exemple candidat vient de jeter l'épongé
ni à chartres ni à bourges ni à la roche
sur yon où ils viennent là aussi de
lâcher la faire c'était trop compliqué
même dans certaines villes où le rn est
très fort où marine le pen enregistre
des scores à plus de 50 % à la
présidentielle il n'y a parfois pas de
liste à amnéville en moselle ou à
courrières dans le pas de calais la
galère ça concerne même les métropoles à
grenoble où le rassemblement national
s'était qualifié au second tour il y a 6
ans est bien là bas le candidat a lancé
un appel à tous les grenoblois original
l'appel
il appelle les grenoblois qui ne partage
pas ses idées à rejoindre ses listes aux
pour le pour la simple raison que le
démocrate a paris alors c'est vrai qu'on
en parle peu il ya un candidat un
rassemblement national à paris c'est
valider ça oui tout à fait et là où
l'adhérent de saint-just et la guerre
agacée panacée pas l'aîné saveurs
chercher des airbus on en parle peu il
ne vient pas du rassemblement national
mais il est soutenu par le rassemblement
national on pouvait penser qu'à paris ça
serait plus facile avec un tel réservoir
d'habitants et bien non c'est là aussi
galère ya plein d'arrondissement où
s'est pas terminée j'ai assisté il ya
quelques semaines à une réunion publique
du candidat et il avait de sacrés
conseil assez originaux pour appâter les
troupes premier conseil candidate et
dans un autre arrondissement pour ne pas
être reconnu par ses voisins deuxième
conseil carrément se présentait sous un
autre nom son nom de jeune fille
de sa femme par exemple pour ne pas
gêner sa carrière professionnelle alors
ces deux conseils sont drôles mais ils
sont surtout révélateur car la morale de
l'histoire c'est qu'il n'y a rien à
faire malgré des années de
dédiabolisation et bien l'étiquette
rassemblement national elle est toujours
dur à augmenter pendant les municipales
dans une toute petite ville comme dans
une grande
merci camille marc fesneau on va pas se
réjouir des difficultés d'adversaires
après tout les marcheurs alors je
rappelle que vous êtes centriste 1 vous
êtes modèle dénommé galère aussi pas mal
dans ces municipales par honnêteté il ya
beaucoup de villes où elle a publié en
mars n'a aussi évident mais je pense que
c'est ça reflète une chose assez simple
c'est que une équipe municipale puisque
c'est une équipe
s'il suffit pas d'avoir un tête de liste
pour y arriver une équipe municipale ça
ne se crée pas comme ça une dynamique ça
ne se crée pas comme ça et c'est valable
pour l'ensemble des formations
politiques le rassemblement national
mais qui n'échappe pas à la règle enfin
je veux dire c'est une mécanique assez
assez simple des 36000 enfin un peu
moins maintenant communes en france ça
fait cinq cent mille élus locaux à
trouver
contrairement à ce qu'on avait dit
d'ailleurs je le dis au passage on avait
dit qu'on va trouver personne je n'ai
pas encore le sentiment qu'on soit en
pénurie de candidats quand même chaque
que tous les six ans se fait peur c'est
la peur du la sixième année en dise on
trouvera jamais de candidat
on arrive quand même à les trouver je
crois moi même candidat simplement sur
la liste dans mon village
voilà c'est une forme d'engagement qui
est particulière et c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de constituer des listes dd on
verra ça donne peut-être que le clivage
gauche-droite ressurgira dans cette
élection municipale en suspens à lyon va
outre-manche à présent avec avec vous à
l'ex direction le royaume uni alors on
croyait que le brésil s'était fait aussi
la tempête allait se calmer que d'une
certaine façon chacun allait retrouver
un peu de sérénité des missions choc
en grande bretagne des missions avec la
nes vous avez vu alors pas des moindres
parce que il ya une semaine le ministre
des finances himself a démissionné
personnes s'y attendait tout un symbole
suel s'agit de david
son père était conducteur de bus ce
pakistanaise sa mère ne parlait même pas
anglais donc c'est tout un symbole en
fait pour reprendre votre jolie
expression il tenait les cordons de la
bourse
et il refusé de financer les monts et
merveilles a promis par son boss et
johnson dans les élections de décembre
mais alors on pensait que c'était fini
puis il ya quatre jours d'émission
encore plus choc d'un conseiller du
district street celui ci qui s'appelle
andrew sa bisbille
alors il avait été embauché samedi
dernier et comme on fait dans le monde
dans lequel nous vivons mais
journalistes sont précipités sur son
compte twitter et ses articles avaient
oublié de d'effacer son passé alors on
tombait sur des choses très sympathiques
comme son soutien à l'eugénisme vous
avez derrière ils sont meilleurs que les
autres sans avis sur le sport où il
disait que le sport féminin ressembler
plus ou paralympiques couvrait sport
masculin et en plus c'est vu sympathique
sur la stérilisation de masse pour les
couche intérieure de la société doit
voir et j'en passe mais comment c'est
possible problème c'est ce monsieur il
s'appelle coming dominique trompe reynet
c'est la puissance grise derrière
johnson qui me connaissaient peut-être
celui qui a manipulé les données
facebook pour faire gagner le référendum
sur le bike site il ya un très bon un
téléfilm qui se perdaient en ce beau
bourg la guerre peut civile avec tom
unique comme patch qui joue son rôle je
vous le recommande
en fait il est machiavélique en morse et
d'éminentes crise mais le problème c'est
qu'il est complètement taré j'en ai la
preuve regardez cet extrait c'est un
joint à ce que la chopine devant chez
lui la semaine dernière pour lui
demander de parler d'un prochain tgv
écouter ses réponses selon vous le
projet hsd est un désastre
pourquoi il a le feu vert
pour l'heure c'est pas l'heure de
convaincre le malheur je trouve pas
qu'on prive difficile de traduire parce
qu'il parlait en rimes et les
complètement pulsar est arrimée il a
incontestablement il a beaucoup de
pouvoir oui il skie comme des élections
et des référendums mais en fait il ya un
peu de rififi avec la petite amie de
bruce thomson sa les coulisses de la
faire en gros en fût oui enfin des
poteaux plus out of the box tumeur donc
ça d'imaginaire fort de sa victoire donc
des élections de décembre ils avaient
lancé des appels de candidatures au 10
downing street en disant qu'il cherchait
des candidats windows mais ce fait ces
gens bizarres et des asociaux des gens
mal assortis il n'a pas été déçu du
voyage parce que ce monsieur s'habille
ski dont vous parlez donc posé sa
candidature on a demandé lundi 30 fois
dans une conférence de presse au 10
downing street si le premier ministre
soutenait ce candidat pas de réponse
mais au fur et à mesure c'est devenu
clair avec donc les journalistes que sa
porte est donc difficilement poliment
justement donc comment apporter victoire
mais à quel prix
en termes d'image de marque ce monsieur
a démissionné à mon avis comme ns ne
fera pas long feu
non plus malgré ce qu'il a apporté à
johnson la folle vie politique des
britanniques
un hommage avec vous bertrand
aujourd'hui
eh bien oui jean daniel est mort et pour
nous tous c'est un personnage
extrêmement important il avait créé en
1964 le nouvel observateur et qu'est ce
qui lie à dos si bien que la chanson
pour voir quelle est la renommée d'un
homme ou d'un journal et ce qui est
étonnant avec le le nouvel obs c'est que
c'est un marqueur politique c'est un
marqueur social c'est un marqueur
culturel et un certain nombre d'artistes
et pas des moindres ont utilisé
le nouvel obs pour définir ce qu'est un
personnage en une chanson pour définir
l'identité culturelle et politique d'un
personnage en voici deux d'un seul coup
c'est pas des petits ch des petits
artistes c'est guy béart et renault
écoutez quand mr lee son bréviaire maman
l'observateur moi je suis contestataires
je me suis fais un voeu qui n'avait pas
oublié les forges biens intellectuels en
loden genre nouvelle offre alors les
lecteurs du nouvel obs alors si guy
béart
c'est intéressant c'est une chanson de
69 qui raconte l'évolution politique
d'une famille
la grand mère lise et son bréviaire
catholique maman est une centriste
puisqu'elle lille nouvel ace et luffy
est à terre gauchistes alors chez
renault dans marshall en 1981 le loubard
de la chanson voir entrer dans son
gastaud ce un intellectuel genre
nouvelles apps et là il ya un gag
uniquement perceptible par une certaine
génération c'est que cet intellectuel
genre nouvel obs est à dire un centriste
c'est à dire le centre gauche plus que
méprise renault 15e gauche voit la
deuxième gauche by renault il est faut
pas oublier qu'il appellerait il a fait
des censures les barricades en mai 68
cet intellectuel porte en loden et le
loden souvenez-vous ce manteau vert
autriche enfin bas la faune et les
pannes et ça existe toujours mais
c'était le manteau giscardienne donc un
lecteur du nouvel obs qui portait un
manteau giscardien c'est un gag un peu
vintage mais je peux pas résister au
plaisir de rendre hommage en même temps
qu'à jean daniel à une autre
personnalité disparu récemment
écoutez bien au nouvel obs il n'y avait
pas que jean daniel dans cette chanson
[Musique]
oui alors 1984 cookie dingler et c'est
une jolie réflexion insu sur le statut
du nouvel obs hebdomadaire sérieux que
lit la femme libérée mais elle ne lit
que les bandes dessinées de brettés cher
qui vient elle aussi de 2 2 et les
chanteurs populaires quand il cite la
presse
c'est en général pour s'en moquer et si
on parle du décorum nouvel obs du
caractère décoratif du nouvel
observateur con con qu'on laisse traîner
négligemment comporte sous le bras et
qui veut dire quelque chose il ya une
chanson très très belle un peu un peu
oubliés du d'une magnifique auteur qui
est isabelle mayereau qui décrit un
intérieur qui lui semble aménagé tout
entier pour la séduire
c'est la chanson standing écouter des
sig ici et là pour le grand sembliez pas
dans un coin sombre de 3 express est
nouvelle
l'express alors qu'est ce que c'est à
côté du nouvel obs
alors d'abord l'express il nouvelles
sont à côté alors c'est un free since a
dit qu' on a du goût puisque on n'est
pas trop de gauche puisqu'on dit
l'express journal de droite
on n'est pas trop de droite parce qu'on
lit le nouvel obs hebdomadaire de gauche
et puis il ya un canon ef le canon ef en
l'occurrence scénario n'est fait c'est à
l'époque c'est la mercedes de l'appareil
photo argentique et c'est très réputé
pour être notamment l'appareil photo
préférée des photographies érotiques
c'est le ccc même un élément de
publicité dans les années 70 pour la
gamme cannon c'est ça ces essais voilà
je vous ai pas résisté au plaisir de ces
petites cartes postales autour du nouvel
obs et de jantes et il a été très fort
merci merguez chronique jean daniel un
mot vous l'avez lu j'imagine oui j'ai
d'abord je connais bien le nouvel obs
que vous avez des tas c'est juste c'est
qu'une fois que ça rentre la chanson
rendre ça veut dire que le nouvel obs
symboliser et jean daniel était le
symbole d'une fronde est quand ça rentre
dans la culture populaire au travers
d'une chanson au fond ou deux chansons
c'est que au fond ça assis quelque chose
de dans la durée et donc c'est aller
bien de rendre au travers de son image
et agent daniele au nouvel obs on va
voir un verre à présent pour terminer
cette émission oui on va boire et on va
découvrir qui est alors on va découvrir
un député qui s'appelle brahim à mouches
qui est également je connais du modem
voilà de députée de moselle
j'ai bu un verre avec lui au café
français qui place de la bastille récit
qui porte bien son nom
et alors c'est un personnage brahim
amoché il est très intéressant il est
passé de philosophie de poésie il est
vraiment passionnant mais surtout c'est
un psychiatre c'est un psychiatre qui
est devenu député d'oak et
indisponibilité alors évidemment vous
pensez bien que j'ai posé la question
qui me semblait la plus importante est
ce qui aurait une forme de continuité
dans son travail
finalement or d'autres termes est-ce
qu'il a pu identifier à l'assemblée des
cas préoccupant j'ai plus de fous à
l'extérieur que j'en avais dans mon
service
est ce que vous diriez que globalement
ça va où on a quand même des pathologies
assez lourde
on a un éventail assez large on a des
idéalistes passionné on a le registre
paranoïaque
on a le registre névrotique voilà il ya
tout ça à l'assemblée j'allais dire j'y
viens depuis peut-être que moi même je
je je dois être dans une de ces
catégories
vous vous êtes si donc il n'ya pas de
hasard exactement ces fraudes qui disait
dans un de ses ouvrages entre le
chirurgien et le boucher il n'y a pas de
différence donc est sympathique c'est
finalement voyez donc qu'il a il a donc
fait un premier diagnostic donc pourquoi
pas passer à la pratique
peut-être au sein de l'assemblée on m'a
déjà proposé d'ouvrir un cabinet à
l'assemblée à côté du médecin
généraliste qui a non non non il est
sinon il y aurait vraiment une confusion
des places mais dont convient parfois on
vient parfois mal alors vous vient
parfois à me voir pour vous voilà mes
mais souvent c'est pour les enfants
continuent un peu le même boulot ou quoi
oui je continue je suis invitée de temps
en temps dans les colloques
j'ai utilisé le même boulot à
l'intérieur de l'assemblée bah ça c'est
quand je vois là quand j'ai un peu de
spleen laplane installe j on attend on
attend le psy à parce que le spleen
cirque alexis bouroz marqué il va rire
très communicatif s'est passé un truc
assez amusant pendant ce tournage à un
moment il m'a parlé de la parité de la
place de l'homme dans l'assemblée et ccd
des sujets qui l'intéressent beaucoup
dans la société aussi mais aussi chez
lui dans son foyer et corridas il a
voulu faire passer savait évidemment
donc il s'est souvenu qu on était filmé
et il a voulu faire passer un petit
message personnel à sa femme
et puis ça s'est fini par un fou rire
j'ai été un peu déstabilisé
regardez bien qu'on soit pas égalité un
mois je le dis en toute façon si ma
femme regarde ambiant mais oui c'est
comme ça la maison rail raconte des
blagues
donc je dis chérie si tu m'écoutes
[Rires]
on me dit j'avais envie communicative
très mauvaise idée
c'est vrai que c'est très communicatif
il est formidable moment rigole voilà
c'est ça d'avoir passé un moment à rire
bon ça vous donne envie de le consulter
marc fesneau d'un mot ça donne envie de
rire parce que je connais bien brave me
moucher alors c'est vrai que à chaque
fois qu'on rencontre les compense
demandant quelle catégorie vous rend
jouit toujours un peu inquiet il faut
rire avec lui ou pas trop reste heureux
merci beaucoup marc fesneau de vous être
prêter à ce jeu sur le plateau de lcp
merci à tous ses amis à dimanche
prochain c'est le week-end profitez bien
[Musique]